you may not have won any competitions
but you still made it to the final five
as a super fan what does that mean to
you
has a super fan of Big Brother making it
to the final five without winning any
competition and it means I must have had
a really strong social game which I am
so proud of
next question you still seem to be upset
with Joseph why did you seem more upset
that he lied to you than your Showman's
Kyle
I was more upset that Joseph lied about
me and made me out to seem like some big
brother Savage who would have voted out
my showmance and my best friend which
just wasn't true so if Joseph is gonna
make up things about my character then
I'm going to be way more angry at him
than Kyle long to me about things in the
game
next question after everything you have
learned about Kyle where do you see your
relationship going in the future
I have no idea where Kyle and I are
going to go in the future we definitely
have a lot of open and honest
conversations to be had which hopefully
we can have a few of them in the jury
house but I also really want to talk to
my friends and family who have seen
everything play out and get their
opinions on it as well before I make any
decisions
next what was your biggest mistake in
the game is there something you wish you
had done differently
my biggest mistake in the game was
letting pose pack Alliance blow up in
front of my face I really should have
strategized with them and made a plan
with them from the beginning and not let
that slip through my fingers
final question did you ever think that
Turner would have voted against you
despite having such a strong friendship
from the beginning
I never ever thought Turner would vote
against me he told me from the beginning
of the game he would never put me up and
he would never vote me out well he put
me up during the double eviction but he
said do you trust me I'll keep you in
this house and then he ended up voting
me out so I was actually really
blindsided by that I'm pretty devastated
but at the end of the day it's a game
and I guess that's what he felt like was
best for his